Using cheat sheets when hand manipulating
stitch patterns on a manual machine is
a great way to keep track of the stitch
transfers without counting
needles or making yourself crazy.
Watch as we knit this simple lace pattern
pattern with the Knit it Now cheat sheets.
Based on this hand-knitting stitch
diagram, I reproduced the stitch
symbols on my sheet.
The circles are eyelets which translate
to an empty needle for machine knitting.
The slants represent the direction
of the stitch transfers.
Remember, as machine knitters,
we're looking at the knitting
from the purl side.
Let's start on row one
of the stitch pattern.
First, I'll orient the chart
to the right of the needles in work.
According to the chart,
I'll skip the first three needles and then
I'll transfer the fourth stitch left
and empty the needle, creating an eyelet.
Moving across the row,
I'll transfer the next eyelet left.
Notice that I've highlighted the eyelet
column to keep myself oriented.
Also notice that I'm working a simple
stitch transfer that will look like this.
Another option is to work
this transfer in two steps.
First picking up the stitch,
transferring it right, then picking up
both stitches to fill the emptied needle.
The difference is subtle and it is
equivalent to a right leaning
decrease in hand knitting.
Right leaning as seen
from the knit side of the work.
I'll continue to transfer across
the row by moving and positioning
the eyelet symbols.
Here, I'm lining up the symbol
with the existing eyelet, positioning
the next symbol for the next transfer.
Shift the chart and line up the symbol
with the eyelet across the rows.
To double check
you can always count the boxes
on the chart and count the needles.
Once the transfers are complete.
My pattern is telling me to knit two rows.
But wait a minute.
Oops! I didn't put the empty needles
into working position and they
didn't form the eyelets properly.
I'll need to rip out this row and free
pass back and then put all needles
in work and continue knitting.
For the next row, I'll hold up the next
row of my chart using the orange
highlighted column and the three
needles orientation.
I'll transfer according to the chart.
One stitch on the left of the original
eyelet column and one stitch on the right.
Again, I'm working a simple stitch
transfer on the left,
but this time I'm working a two
step transfer on the right.
This will form a left-leaning stitch.
When looking at the knit side
of the knitting.
I'll continue to work the second row
of transfers across the row using
the orange highlighted column
to orient the chart as I go.
This time you can see that 2-
step transfer more clearly.
Remembering to put all needles in work
this time, I'll knit four rows,
creating the eyelets.
The next sequence of transfers are
positioned between the previous ones.
Line up the chart using the three stitches
on the right and the orange highlighted
column to position the chart.
Remember, the orange column
represents that first eyelet
on the first row.
Transfer left as indicated on the chart,
keeping the yellow highlighted
column aligned with the new eyelet.
Transfer the next eyelet.
Count needles if you like and use
the orange column to stay oriented.
Slide the chart left
and finish the sequence.
Notice I'm not transferring
along the edge of my piece.
I don't want eyelets right
on the edge of my knitting.
With all needles in work, I'll knit two
rows to complete that set of eyelets.
Finish the sequence by counting needles
on the right and aligning the yellow
highlighted column
with the previous eyelet.
Transfer left and right
of that center eyelet.
Keeping the chart aligned,
transfer the next set of stitches
and repeat across the row.
Keep using that yellow highlighted column
to confirm the position of the chart
and transfer the last set of stitches.
Take time to confirm the accuracy
of the position of the eyelets
and transfers, and knit four rows.
When looking at the knitting
from the purl side, it's difficult to see
the right and left-leaning transfers.
I suggest you experiment
with the appearance of each and use
the appropriate technique
to get the results you want.
Remember, a two-step transfer will lean
in the direction that the doubled-up
stitches are transferred
in relation to the eyelet.
For a simple stitch pattern like this,
you might want to choose to work simple
transfers because the appearance of left
and right leaning isn't as noticeable.
The beauty of this stitch are the eyelets,
But be aware of the differences
with more complex stitch patterns.